so one interesting philosophical point
and quantum mechanics bring up is the
that you talk about the distinction
between the world as it is and the world
as we observe it so staying at the human
level for a second how big is the gap
between what our perception system
allows us to see and the world as it is
outside our minds I sort of sort of not
at the quantum mechanical level yeah as
just are these particular tools we have
which is a few senses and cognitive
abilities to process those senses well
that last phrase having the cognitive
abilities to process them carries a lot
right I mean there is our sort of
intuitive understanding of the world you
don't need to teach people about gravity
for them to know that apples fall from
trees right that's something that we
figure out pretty quickly object
permanence things like that the three
dimensionality of space even if we don't
have the mathematical language to say
that we kind of know that it's true
on the other hand no one opens their
eyes and sees atoms all right or
molecules for ourselves for that matter
forget about quantum mechanics so but we
got there we got to understanding that
there are atoms and cells using the
combination of our senses and our
cognitive capacities so adding the
ability of our cognitive capacities to
our senses is adding an enormous amount
and I don't think there's a
hard-and-fast boundary you know if you
believe in cells if you believe that we
understand those then there's no reason
you believe we can't believe in quantum
mechanics just as well
you